bueno las últimas informaciones que se
han tenido en los últimos minutos de
exact loción que éste sintió en las
cercanías de la parte norte del
aeropuerto
esta tarde según asegurando entre
americanos había sido un misil con el
que habrían atacado un coche en el cual
se trasladaba un terrorista en un coche
lleno de explosivos ya en los últimos
días después del fatídico
atentado en el aeropuerto que dejó más
de 170 muertos y algunos oficiales ya se
había dicho que posiblemente venía otro
atentado así lo ha venido diciendo el
presidente norteamericano joe biden así
que éste habría sido un coche de uno de
sus integrantes de isis y ya se ha dicho
desde eeuu que seguirán tratando de
detener estos posibles ataques en las
últimas horas de la presencia
norteamericana recordemos que ya la
noche de ayer fueron los últimos vuelos
británicos
las únicas tropas que se encuentran
dentro de cada uno en este momento son
los norteamericanos hasta hoy se dice
que van a evacuar a los últimos civiles
que tienen acceso a informaciones que
llegan desde las cercanías de ese
aeropuerto dicen que hay muchísima menos
presencia de civiles alrededor mil
personas tratando de evacuar en estas
últimas horas y a partir de allá del día
de mañana lo que queda es evacuar esas
tropas norteamericanas alrededor de 4000
que quedan en el país lo que también
sabemos es que los talibanes han dicho
que están listos para tomar el control
del aeropuerto que tienen ingenieros que
tienen especialistas para hacerlo y hay
otras informaciones llegadas desde otros
medios todavía sin confirmar ellos le
habían ofrecido a los gobierno turco de
que tuvieran control del aeropuerto para
fines civiles y parecería que habían
llegado a un acuerdo para empezar a
operarlo en las últimas de las próximas
horas